DR. TONY PADILLA: The GIMPS
have been at it again.
They've found a new prime
number, the largest prime
number that's been
found to date.
The GIMPS, of course, are the
Great Internet Mersenne Prime
Search team, a network of
computers and people that work
on these computers that look
for large Mersenne primes.
It's a pretty big number, 2 to
the power-- now, I've got to
remember this, now--
57,885,161 minus 1.
So the 57,885,161 is
a prime number.
But this bad boy, the whole
thing, is also a
prime number, of course.
It's a much bigger one.
And that is the largest
prime number ever
to have been found.
It's the 48th Mersenne
prime ever to have
been found as well.
BRADY HARAN: Can you remind us
what a Mersenne prime is?
DR. TONY PADILLA: Yes.
So essentially, the Mersenne
prime-- you just take 2.
You take it to some power, P--
and this is a prime
number-- minus 1.
And that's your Mersenne
prime.
It's pretty interesting how
they've gone about finding
this, as well.
There's various things
about it.
For example, the way
it's done is they
have this GIMPS network.
They're a network of
shared computers.
And they use their combined
computing power to basically
work out, try and find
these prime numbers.
So it's quite interesting, this
sort of collaboration
going on to find these things.
From my point of view, it's
actually reminiscent of
something that they do at the
LHC to manage the data.
They basically use a network of
computers around the world
to analyze that data.
So it's not always academics
that are finding these things.
Anybody can get involved
in the project.
And there's money on the table,
as well, when it comes
to finding these things.
Curtis Cooper will win--
it looks like $3,000 for
finding this number.
It's a bit of a shame
for him because
this number, actually--
well, it has this many digits.
It's this many digits long.
It is 17,425,170 digits
long, I think.
The reason this is a little bit
annoying for Curtis Cooper
is that it's not 100 million
digits long.
Because if it had been 100
million digits long, then he
would have won $150,000.
Because that's the prize on
offer if he can find one
that's actually that long.
It's worth thinking about how
big this number actually is.
And we've talked about big
numbers in the past, Brady.
It is bigger than a googol.
It's not as big as
a googolplex.
It's certainly not as big
as Graham's number.
You can easily think of this
number without your head
collapsing to form
a black hole.
There's no problem there.
In fact, actually, it's quite
easy to think of.
You could even memorize
this number.
Here we have the number.
So this is the number written
out in full--
quite a big file.
There you go.
It's got 17 and 1/2
million digits.
This file is about 22 meg.
Now, apparently, your brain can
store about 2.5 million
gig of memory.
So technically, you could
memorize this number without
having a problem.
And in fact, I'm going to be
cocky here because I actually
can write this.
I'm going to write
this number.
I've remembered this number.
But I've remembered
it in base 2.
OK.
So let me write down
it out in base 2.
I was quite impressed that
I remembered this.
So the first number is 1.
The second number--
ah, it's also 1.
And the next one's also 1.
And the next one is also 1.
And I would carry on writing 1's
until I got all the way to
the last number, which
is also 1.
And there would be
a grand total of
57,885,161 of these 1's.
And that is the number
written in base 2.
So I can prove that for
you if you'd like.
BRADY HARAN: Go on.
DR. TONY PADILLA: OK.
So the reason that that's
what it is in base 2--
OK.
So let's look at this number.
Let's just call it P for now,
rather than this 57 million.
Because we can prove
this in generality.
I can actually factorize
this expression.
And I can factorize this
expression as follows.
It's 2 minus 1.
That's obviously 1--
multiplied by 1, plus 2, plus
2 squared, all the way up
to 2 P minus 1.
OK.
So this is obviously
1 out front.
So what I'm left with is just
all the, basically, essential
units of base 2 with
1's in front.
And that's it.
So that's the proof.
So there's obviously P
of these in total.
So in our case, P
is 57,885,161.
And so this is how you would
write it out in base 2.
BRADY HARAN: In base 10, which
is what more people are
familiar with, what's the
first and last digit?
DR. TONY PADILLA: So I'm going
to have to look this one up.
Well, I think I know the
first, actually.
actually.
It's 5, isn't it?
It's 5.
And the last one-- can I look?
BRADY HARAN: Yeah.
DR. TONY PADILLA: I've got a
feeling the last one's--
well, we know it's going to be
an odd number, don't we?
So we've got 1.
There we go.
Of course, we have a new perfect
number from this.
And it's very easy to write
down what it is.
And the perfect number
that we have--
2 to the 57,885,160, multiplied
by 2 to the
57,885,161 minus 1.
That's our new perfect number.
It's about 34 million
digits long.
Yep.
That's our new perfect number
we've got out of this.
So whew.
It's all good fun, basically.
And I think that there is an
important point to come from--
these searches.
I mean, they're fun to look at.
It's nice.
It's interesting.
Oh, we found this new,
big prime number.
There's a lot of technology
that goes into sort of
developing the software to
do these calculations.
Because basically, if you
actually tried to calculate
all the divisors of this guy,
you've used all the numbers
that were smaller than it and
tried to see if they were
factors of that number, if you
did that, just like that, sort
of blindly, you'd find that you
needed more than the age
of the universe to actually
do that calculation.
So there's sophisticated
techniques at work here.
And all this game, and all this
developing this computing
power in particular ways to
multiply large numbers, really
have had sort of impact
elsewhere, for example.
It's the spinoff technologies
that are coming from this sort
of really mathematicians
playing games.
But you should never knock
mathematicians playing games.
Because the crumbs that fall
off the table can be of
benefit to everybody else.
BRADY HARAN: If you'd like to
see even more from this
interview, including a rather
strange discussion about my
family tree, I've got an
unlisted video with all the
off cuts and extra footage.
I basically didn't put it as a
listed video because I didn't
want to clog up everyone's
subscription boxes.
And if you want to find out
more about some of these
topics and you haven't watched
our back catalogue of videos,
I've also put links to our films
about Mersenne primes,
perfect numbers, googols and
googolplexes, Graham's number,
all that kind of stuff.
Check out the links under the
video or here on the screen.